will we still get christmas prime
minister
for months he's wanted to play santa not
scrooge
over restrictions number 10's present to
everyone after a
difficult year but spiraling case
numbers bring
into sharp relief whether the benefit
now is outweighed by the cost in january
as ministers decide whether to change
tack
already the messaging is shifting the
message around christmas
almost irrespective of what the rules
say is it look if you don't need
to do it if you don't need to hug your
grandparents you don't need to be in
that
sort of you know intimate arrangement
don't
you don't wait you don't have to wait
until a rule book comes out to be able
to deploy
a common sense but labour want more than
that
pressure from the leader of the
opposition who wrote to the prime
minister calling for an
urgent review of the coveted christmas
restrictions
doing nothing is not really viable i
think a responsible government is going
to have to do
something i don't want to make this
party political we know people want to
see each other
families want to see each other this
won't come as a
as a pleasant surprise to families so
i'm saying to the government to the
responsible thing
review toughen up and we will support
you if you do that
but this decision isn't just for
westminster to determine
different messages from scotland and
wales i would urge
the utmost caution if you can avoid
mixing with other households over
christmas
especially indoors then please do so
approaching
the welsh government too releasing this
video urging caution at christmas
don't put yourself and your family at
risk for the sake of tradition
but the first minister in wales is
reluctant to give up the rules he's
already committed to
the four nation agreement over christmas
was hammered out in detail over four
different meetings between the four
nations it was a hard one agreement i
will not likely
put it aside the man in here leaders of
all four nations have got to look at
evidence
data policy options but people have made
plans they've booked travel they've
bought food they've got
presents this is politics intruding into
the most
personal the most intimate parts of
people's lives
it's no surprise that no firm decision
was reached tonight
but two leading health publications say
the status quo on christmas is
untenable and urged ministers to follow
more cautious examples set by european
nations
other european countries have also had
very difficult autumns
what's different perhaps between them
and the way the british government is
reacting
is that they have acknowledged that the
facts have changed
that there is significantly more
infection and hospitalization
going on now than they hoped to be the
case and they have
restricted movement over over christmas
as a result of that
on the one hand boris johnson breaks his
christmas pledge to voters
on the other he risks more infections
more deaths more locked down
an impossible choice sam coates
sky news